[Music]
and too dangerous news you saw danger
with submitted by the assassin of
Jamelia oh I have names as a violent
prisoner had his charges dropped because
he's too dangerous for court okay
yeah discharges dropped mm-hmm so the
judge is so scared that he didn't even
want him to be in court with him
is this a [ __ ] old chapel that's
crazy but just let's just keep him out
with the [ __ ] public instead of
putting him in jail because I'm too
scared to have oh I know he's a
well-connected mafia members but El
Chapo dude I know he doesn't want him
defeated his face so that's why he's
like if he sees my face I'm dead Kudus
be before I even tell you any of you
tells I'm gonna show you his picture oh
my god just he's covered in [ __ ] looks
like malicious looking us he's probably
scary what what stop [ __ ]
we're worse than scary guy this is it
what why what I don't understand what I
gotta explain to me what's going on
right now yes no reaction I like how
he's doing a lap post but he has no
laughs what country is is he got to be
the safest country on Earth so his name
is Andrew he's 25 years old from
Scotland this guy he has a series of
violent convictions he has I was dealing
with some stuff is Alex vandalism
assault resisting arrest making false
allegations against prison officers
biting open the veins in his arms and
spraying people with his blood I'm
talking crazy assaulted a nurse when he
escaped from a hospital in England he
attacked a jail warden and hit a nurse
on the back with a chair and he so he's
also refusing to be searched after
claiming that
he has like she's now a woman and so she
changed his name to Tiffany Scott he
doesn't sound that violent you guys but
imagine this oh so maybe he they're
dropping they can bring him in like the
guy from signs of the land well he just
doesn't sound that crazy for like
American standards yeah yeah
look what the craziest thing is ripping
out your [ __ ] veins and spraying your
blood that's pretty gross I think what
really crossed the line for officials is
the fact that he assaulted a Joe Ward
antenna nurse yeah yeah but they can't
handle that like that's pretty standard
here
I thought you signed up so you can
handle done get efficient so there's a
Mike he's one of 100 prisoners with an O
L R which stands for order for life long
restriction so this means that he will
be released when he is no longer
considered and unmanageable risks to
public safety so he is not released to
the public is just that his charges has
been dropped because he's too dangerous
to appear in court according to
officials they're just going to
incarcerate him for life for being a
crazy act until he's not a riff that
sounds illegal too though yeah how do
they evaluate that that either okay now
he's ready to be released
they have like behavioral evaluations
yeah thank you yeah I just look at him
and go wow they're scared of him he
looks like one of the kids from Harry
Potter
if you throw in American jail system
like the prison girl just beat the [ __ ]
out of yeah and maybe we should have a
prison exchange system and then we
should spend hours to a third-world
country
oh they would run that [ __ ] [ __ ] in
my [ __ ] transmission that's sure they
would run the prison they'll take over
the country at oh you know what never
mind like you know in the Mexican Mafia
they have their own boot camps in there
they could they could run their own boot
camp in secret you forget it forget it
highly sophisticated all right let's
give the jailers will smart
or maybe they can go to the nice jails
in Europe and then they go away what
they don't see you like a criminal here
I mean beforehand yeah and then maybe
they become intentional
regular people yeah so they're saying
that he is thought to be an extreme
threat to the public and he's too
violent to transport oh come on they're
acting like this was [ __ ] had a
collector and [ __ ]
I mean it's put them in a straitjacket
but the [ __ ] being on it is straight
you don't even need that he comes and he
starts acting like you take a Billy cub
to the [ __ ] back of his head knocking
the [ __ ] out call them through drag them
out definitely do the math oh yeah but I
don't understand
in America you get electrified so the
reaction from the members of the same
Union as the nurse in the jail wardens
they are really really serious because
he's saying that even though he's still
going to remain in prison that he should
still be charged for the times that he's
committed correct
oh yeah I agree you know if he knows how
to play the batteries there's not to
play the bagpipes yeah yeah you know how
like the the people here they play the
harmonica in jail or like in the movies
do you think like in Scotland they play
the bagpipes in the spare time
I'm a doctor blue can Rosanna ignorant
American every episode no we don't
curious Americans is the word not
ignorant because you know what
we're not supposed to know everything
and no question is a dumb question
because you have to learn there's some
dumb one no it's not well your point
about we're not supposed to know
everything is a good point yeah because
I've never been to Scotland
I think Bart's question is legitimate I
see groundskeeper Willie in [ __ ] jail
with the bagpipes ad playing the
Scottish Blues that they're the Labour
hey have you guys seen um school lunches
from around the world yes everywhere is
healthier but the United States do you
think the same for the jail system they
probably eat healthier than we do once I
got my meat pies over there I think so
was America the one that industrialized
buy packaged food like
like we're we the ones that started that
no like in terms of like you know like
team dinners hostess Twinkie it seems
like a very mark combined I feel like it
was an America right because like that
wasn't called the jungle or whatever so
let me go to it but what about it
well I think because that's that's a
part of our history and our football so
that's why I foods like a lot of
processed food here and that's just how
it you know it's a part of our culture
that's so true like if you go to like my
family mart or any like asian
convenience store there's the stuff yeah
the stuff that's in like this type of
packaging it's minimal and you have a
lot of actual like baked pastries or
actual food food that's made but if you
go to 7-eleven it's everything is this
and then there's that one like hotdog
display so it's like complete opposite
yeah well corner this quick google
search they say the first metal can was
invented in 1809 after general napoleon
bonaparte they made an offer a twelve
thousand front for anyone who can invent
a method to preserve food for his army
also like military food less interesting
so Chef Boyardee is a military chef I
didn't know that do I [ __ ] used to
love those ravioli oh hell yeah I am
alphabet soup never happens you can do
those get Alton ravioli I used to love
that [ __ ]
I hear I should with white bread all the
time what about SpaghettiOs because it
is but they didn't have the dog food
beef inside that's right like the water
out sour taste to it and I like
SpaghettiOs I think we should do a
castle tour I'm down in Cortland yeah
haunted no I want to but like Game of
Thrones though yeah go okay so what are
you more scared of are you more scared
of European ghosts or Asian go hey you
know big windows really I think more
scared of Asians oh don't be more
assuming I didn't grow up with Asian
folklore I don't know because like
European ghosts
they're just shackled and they've been
through a lot of like Asian people just
[ __ ] and they fun to come out the
back of your head and you rip your eyes
out of [ __ ] Asian ghosts are old
yeah like older they are the more
[ __ ] angry yeah the European ghosts
are like the headless like the Headless
Horseman versus like the ring the ring
would [ __ ] that bull up dude but that I
don't know headless Horseman's like so
old
yeah but they like Ghost Rider he's kind
of cool but what about a banshee though
yeah be a scream yeah what like what's
the start it's a lady that screams in
the air
yeah I've been bust your eardrums yeah
man I believe so there's the Asian mom
I'm used to that old gargoyles Oh toward
their goals they're cool
well we're thinking about the cart - but
goggles are supposed to be flying demons
oh [ __ ] oh I like the cartoon doesn't my
favorite cartoon yeah did you have I had
two toys though another kid I did see
one account oh dude yeah gone boils I
just think that Scotland is a very nice
place because if they think that this
boy is crazy
at the end of the day I kind of want to
visit Scotland hey guys thanks for
watching that last episode did you love
it I know you did so make sure to give
this video a big thumbs up and to watch
more videos you can watch them up the
soup
[Music]
you
[Music]